>> ♪ ♪
>> [LAUGHING].
>> S& L DAVIDSON SAID I REFUSED
TO DO COLLEGE AFTER THIS YEAR.
YOU ARE SETTING YOURSELF UP FOR
TROUBLE.
NOT THE FIRST TO WRITE OFF THE
HOME OF DWINDLING FREE SPEECH.
WHY IS IT GETTING SO BAD?
2 WORDS.
IDENTITY POLITICS.
I CAN'T LIST THE OFFENDED
WITHOUT TRIGGERING OUT RAGE.
THE LEFT CREATED GROVANCES AND
OFFENSIVES.
THERE ARE MORE IDENTITIES THAN
PEOPLE.
THICK SKINS HAVE BEEN REPLACED
WITH OPEN WOUNDS.
SO -- WHAT CAN TODAY'S COMICS
SAY TO THOSE WHO DEMAND TO BE
SHIELDED FROM OFFENSIVE JOKES?
RATHER THAN SHARE THE RISK, THEY
BAIL.
THE FRONT LINES OF SPEECH ARE IN
RETREAT LEAVING A FEW TO FIGHT
ON.
IT'S UP TO US TO IGNORE THE
FIGHTERS.
IF NOT THE JOKE WILL BE ON ALL
OF US AND NO ONE WILL BE
LAUGHING BECAUSE WE WILL ALL BE
SUING.
EMILY, I HOPE YOU WERE AWAKE
FOR.
THAT SHOULDN'T COMEDIANS GO TO
THE PLACES AND DARE TO BE
CANCELLED LIKE WE DO ON THIS
SHOW.
>> THAT'S THE AIM BUT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING CANCELLED AND LOCKING
ARMS THAT OTHER STUDENTS CAN'T
PENETRATE TO ATTEND A TALK.
I WISH THAT PETE DAVIDSON AND
PEOPLE LIKE HIM COULD BE BRAVE
ENOUGH TO SAY I WILL DO IT
ANYWAY.
WHY SHOULD HE DO IT?
SO HE CAN GET CANCELLED SO
PEOPLE WON'T BE ABLE TO ATTEND?
I WAS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
FEDERALIST SOCIETY.
MY JOB WAS TO PROVIDE THE OTHER
SIDE FOR EVERY DEBATE.
SAN FRANCISCO WAS LIBERAL AND I
NEVER GOT THAT.
IT WAS WELCOME TO HAVE TWO
SIDES.
THE UNPOPULAR WOULD GET DUMPED
ON AFTERWARD.
WHEN I SEE BERKELEY IT MAKES ME
SAD THAT LEVEL OF IGNORANCE IS
PREVENTING THE DISCOURSE.
>> WE DON'T WANT YOU SAD, EMILY.
JUAN, THIS CRITICISM IS
TRANSCENDING POLITICS.
BILL MARR, YOU SO HIM.
CONSERVATIVES PROBABLY SAW IT
COMING BEFORE THE LEFT
THE CONSERVATIVES GOT HIT
EARLIER ON CAMPUSES.
>> BILL MARR GOT CANCELLED BY
CONSERVATIVES.
>> AND ALSO BY THE LEFT WHEN WE
USED THE "N" WORD.
>> I AGREE.
NOT ONLY BILL BUT DAVE CHAPEL
SPOKE OUT ABOUT IT.
BUT THEY HAVE GONE TO HBO AND
NETFLIX AND DO FINE.
IT'S AN OLDER AND BROADER
AUDIENCE.
I THINK YOUNG PEOPLE ARE MORE
SENSITIVE TO THE IDEA YOU ARE
SPEAKING IN A WAY THAT IS
OFFENSIVE.
>> IT'S SO SAD.
>> I AGREE.
I SEE EVEN BIG CORPORATIONS WILL
NOT TAKE YOU ARE TOO POLITICAL.
THEY DON'T WANT TO OFFEND AN
INTEREST GROUP.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
JESSE, THE IDEA OF SENSITIVITY.
IT'S HARMFUL TO PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A THICK SKIN OR
GET NOWHERE.
>> I BLAME LIBERALS.
THEY CREATED POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS.
NOW THEY ARE DEPRIVED OF FUNNY
JOKES ON COLLEGE.
LIBERAL COMEDIANS CAN'T GET THE
GIGS DONE.
IT'S LIKE THE ROBOTS.
YOU CREATE THE ROBOTS AND THEY
COME RUNNING AND SHOOT YOU.
THIS IS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
>> THAT'S A GOOD ANALOGY.
>> POLITICAL CORRECTNESS IS
DEVOURING THE PEOPLE WHO CREATED
IT.
>> YOU KNOW HOW EPSON DOESN'T
WANT TO GO TO SYRIA BECAUSE IT'S
TOO DANGEROUS?
THAT'S HOW COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE
NOW.
IT'S LIKE THE SYRIA OF THIS
COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT WORTH IT.
THERE IS TOO MUCH TO LOSE.
IN THE '80s, JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO, COLLEGE CAMPUSES, THE
CRAZIEST, EDGIEST MOST HILARIOUS
PLACES THERE EVER WAS.
THAT'S WHERE PEOPLE WANTED TO
GO.
REMEMBER SPRING BREAK AND DELTA
HOUSE AND THE COSTUMES.
NOW IT'S JUST THE OPPOSITE.
>> DANA, YOU HAD CRAZY TIMES IN
COLLEGE.
YOU WERE A HELL-RAISER.
>> I DON'T THINK A COMEDIAN EVER
GAME.
IT WAS COLORADO.
>> THEY HAD A RODEO CLOWN.
>> THERE IS A PLACE IN NEW YORK
CALLED THE COMEDY CELLAR.
>> IT'S AN ACTUAL CELLAR.
>> THERE IS A COMEDIAN THERE
NAMED JESSICA.
I LEARNED TO HER POD CASTS.
VERY, VERY FUNNY.
SHE JUST RIPS REPUBLICANS UP ONE
SIDE AND DOWN THE OTHER.
I LAUGH.
SHE INTERVIEWS OTHER COMEDIANS
AND THEY TALK ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
CENSORING THEMSELVES ON STAGE TO
PREVENT THIS CANCELLING.
>> I WENT TO SEE -- I FORGOT HIS
NAME.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THE GUY WHO RANT?
>> OH, THE GUY FROM DO THE RIGHT
THING.
TALL OBNOXIOUS GUY.
>> YES.
HE WAS DOING A STAND UP IN NEW
YORK.
HE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING
POLITICAL.
HE IS FAMOUS FOR ANTI-TRUMP
RANT.
HE SAID I WAS WARNED BY FRIENDS
NOT TO GET POLITICAL.
HE DIDN'T AND EVERYONE WAS LIKE
WHY DID WE COME?
THAT'S THE FUNNY PART.
>> MICHAEL?
>> YES, HIS FIRST NAME IS
MICHAEL.